here in germany coronavirus case numbers
are rising and they are rising fast for
the ninth straight day the country has
registered record infection rates
prompting doctors and health uh public
health experts once again to sound the
alarm they're urging leaders to ramp up
pressure on unvaccinated people and the
first states have started to heed their
call
berlin the latest state to leave the
unvaccinated out in the cold
bars restaurants and cultural venues are
now off limits to those who haven't had
their shot
i'm not thrilled of course but i think
it's important that we all pull together
and also enforce compulsory masks and of
course protect ourselves including those
who are most vulnerable
the so-called 2g rule is meant to stop
rising covered 19 infection rates
and encourage skeptics to get the shot
some politicians think the rule needs to
be expanded
it's been festive
i'm firmly convinced that we need
blanket 2g measures and more in order to
get through the winter safely especially
for indoor activities
this pandemic has been driven by the
unvaccinated and we have to get the
whole thing under control again
otherwise within probably two weeks the
number we have now in intensive care
units will grow so much that we will
reach our limit in germany
the country's next leaders remain locked
in talks to form a new government
they're considering tougher measures
including making vaccines mandatory for
health care workers
one company however is taking matters
into its own hands
offering employees a hefty bonus if they
get the shot
everybody who can prove they've been
fully vaccinated by the beginning of
next year will get a 5 000 euro bonus
even if they're already vaccinated today
they can also look forward to the reward
and those who get vaccinated before then
will benefit too
bosses admit the offer is as much about
protecting their workers as protecting
their business during the christmas
season
if it works it may just give germany's
political leaders something to think
about in the face of stubbornly low
vaccination rates
for more let's cross over to our
correspondent anya schaffenoth in berlin
anya
the infection rate is rising and that's
put the government in a tight spot what
action do we expect from them
well tommy the current spike in
infections has caught germany at a bit
of a tricky time in a way because of
course we're waiting for for the
formation of a new government and that's
left a bit of a decision-making vacuum
in a way but angela merkel is of course
still in power for now and she is
meeting the heads of germany's federal
states on thursday to thrash out a new
corona strategy to address what's fast
becoming really quite a dramatic
situation and but in the meantime
many of the german states have already
introduced their own new rules we saw it
there in berlin but also bavaria
saxony have introduced new restrictions
uh for the unvaccinated uh barring them
from access to many areas of of public
life and now the parties that are likely
to take over the government here in a
few weeks time are already discussing
much stricter measures and they're
discussing restrictions on public
transport possibly even a vaccine
mandate for certain professions like
people working with the elderly or
within nurseries something that we
haven't seen here yet and
so it's not quite a lockdown for the
unvaccinated like we saw austria
introduced this week but certainly
making life for the unvaccinated more
and more difficult in an effort to sort
of push people to reconsider and have
the jab after all
now germany seemed to handle the early
stages of the pandemic relatively well
so have we got to this point
well i think it bears repeating that
these really are the worst figures we've
seen and worst infection rates we've
seen in the whole of the pandemic the
figures we're seeing right now and
although the situation in intensive care
units is not quite as bad as it was
during the first waves of the pandemic
and it is in many areas that are worst
affected that's mainly the east and the
south of germany hospitals there are
getting to their limit are at their
limit many of them having to transfer
patients covert patients to less
affected areas in in germany and
but the main reason for that really is
that just not enough people have got
themselves vaccinated here the the full
vaccination rate here in germany is
stagnating at around 67 percent and
that's quite a bit lower than many other
european um countries like france or
spain and it's simply not enough and
we're also seeing more um breakthrough
infections amongst the vaccinated now
that's because immunity is waning after
the first shots they really need to go
out and get a booster with winter
approaching now people are socializing
indoors more and that's why we're seeing
figures
shooting up like that
okay
uh dw's anya schaffernoth in berlin
thank you
for more on this i'm joined by our
political correspondent benjamin alvarez
gruber in munich
can you give us a picture of the general
situation in bavaria
good morning tomy yeah we just heard
about the situation in one hospital but
unfortunately that's not the only case
there are several hospitals here in
germany's second most popular state that
have severe problems not only with bats
but also with staff when it comes to
treating covet 19 patients
and it's important also to remember that
the problem with baths does not only
concern people with a covet 19
infections but also people for example
that have a heart attack or a stroke
they could also need to wait for a bad
so it is indeed a critical situation in
bavaria and that's where the state of
emergency was declared last week as well
and what is the bavarian regional
government doing to combat the rising
numbers
as i just mentioned they declared a
state of emergency state a leader also
the state premier of bavaria marco suda
said that this week is the week of truth
that they need to be that people need to
reduce their contact and also with new
measures that are in place starting
today there will be a so-called 2g rule
meaning that people who are either fully
vaccinated or recovered from covet 19
will be able to go to restaurants inside
or outside and also to hotels and there
will also be other measures for example
for the christmas market that you can
see just behind me they're setting up
and preparing everything there will be
parts of this christmas market where
only people who fully have been
vaccinated or recovered from the virus
will be able to visit
so that's why they are trying also to
reduce
movement and their calls growing they
say that this christmas market should
even be cancelled considering the high
number of new infections here in bavaria
and how did the situation escalate in
this manner
to me i think there are several reasons
for that when we look not only in
bavaria but also in germany so on one
side we have the vaccination rate that
less than 70 percent have been fully
vaccinated against covet 19 in germany
then of course we have the seasonal
aspect of winter temperatures now four
degrees here in munich meaning that many
people stay indoors with the risk of an
infection is definitely higher then we
have a patchwork of restrictions in
germany with some states
going with this 2g versions and others
taking a 3g
approach meaning that people who have a
negative test can also go to restaurants
or indoor places
several health experts have been warning
for this situation but politicians also
let's remember that we had elections in
september said that it's fear-mongering
promised that there would not be a
lockdown so there are several reasons to
explain that as a some health experts
say the only surprise is that people are
actually surprised by the critical
situation in germany right now
okay thank you that's the uh dw's
benjamin alvarez gruber in munich
you